[Música]
lá na mesa dela tenha dez anos e hoje eu
vim falar sobre os benefícios do esporte
para a saúde mental esporte saúde são
coisas que andam sempre juntas a prática
esportiva de forma regular ajuda a
manter nossa saúde física e mental
sempre em boas condições de saúde mental
na vida no campo na quadra na raia no
tatame saber lidar bem com os êxitos e
fracassos é o segredo
a chave não existir mais saber a hora de
parar não se diminuir mas também nos
agigantar demais saber que o mais
terrível dos adversários somos nós
mesmos
mesmo com todas as nossas dores teimosia
sem consequências e egocentrismo faz
voltei o sport que o atleta faz
acrobacias em cima do cavalo
eu voltei a me ajudar com equilíbrio a
concentração a saúde mental ea superar
os meus meses super essa
assim como na vida no esporte até mesmo
ser chato com a nossa capacidade de
superação e ao mesmo tempo sabendo
respeitar nosso limite e aprendemos com
as derrotas e com as vitórias a exemplo
de superação
um exemplo de superação é de wagner
domingos o brasileiro chegou à final do
lançamento de martelo
aldinete 84 anos e comemorou sua
classificação como se fosse uma medalha
a final em 2011 o brasileiro foi
diagnosticada com câncer na bexiga
passou por cirurgias e cinco anos depois
de estarem no rio 2016
outro exemplo de rafaela silva
a brasileira foi bombardeada por
mensagens racistas em 2012
após ser eliminada de uma competição por
um golpe ilegal pensa em largar o
esporte mas superou e atingiu seu maior
auge na olimpíada
michael phelps simples deve conhecer ele
mas não história de superação
michael phelps sofreu com drogas pensa
em suicídio mas superou com a sua
clínica de reabilitação resolver o
problema pessoal
mas e voltou a freqüentar o lugar que
tanto conhece o ponto mais alto do pódio
agora vou mostrar pra vocês um vídeo de
uma pessoa que admiro muita história na
verdade dilma muda 6 de maio todos os 97
muito grande que não tinha há uns e eu
estava e ainda é ele venceu na disputa
mas não não serviu pra mim poder
entender o sentimento dos meus amigos
muito melhor e com isso construir uma
academia
essa é uma parte da escola dele não é
todo mundo mas tem alguns alunos e
professores
minha história de superação como disse
faz voltei 10 meus quatro anos
um dia cai do cavalo fiquei com muito
medo
minha treinadora me perguntou se queria
voltar
achei que nunca mais é fazer o esporte
mas voltei e por isso em 2014
recebi é esse troféu de superação no
clube o treino e você pratica esporte
diariamente têm algumas tarefas
interessa pra contar
obrigada pela atenção espero que tenham
gostado da minha apresentação
[Música]